There's a powerful David versus
Goliath lesson emerging from
Russia's brazen, unprovoked invasion
of Ukraine.
That should give deep pause to
global superpowers who think they
can simply muscle the world into
whatever shape they want.
Every Russian tank that gets fried
in Ukraine is sending the message
that traditional armies can no
longer expect to dominate simply
because they have more troops,
weapons and money.
Russian armored vehicles are falling
victim to next generation light
anti-tank weapons, NLAWS,
which can be carried by individual
soldiers unslung in seconds
and deployed with little training
but deadly accuracy.
There are credible reports that
Russia has already lost $5
billion worth of military equipment
in just a month of fighting in
Ukraine. That's the reality of
contemporary warfare.
Smaller, nimbler groups fighting
back effectively against lumbering
dumb relics of the past.
Despite being the fifth largest
fighting force on the planet and
starting the war with five times
the number of active military as
Ukraine, Russia has been stymied
in what virtually all observers
expected to be a cakewalk.
The human cost for Russia is
even more staggering.
Nearly 10,000 soldiers killed
in action, including at least five
generals.
Which isn't to say that Russia
isn't also inflicting massive,
horrific violence against Ukraine,
or that it won't prevail in this
conflict, especially the longer
things drag on.
But this war underscores what James
Dale Davidson and Lord William
Rees-Mogg called the changing logic
of violence and the diminishing
returns to violence in their
prophetic 1997 book
The Sovereign Individual.
As weapons have become smaller,
cheaper, more effective and more
widely dispersed.
It's harder and harder for old style
militaries to quickly and
effectively achieve their objectives
through brute force as they meet
resistance at every turn.
That resistance includes information
warfare such as hacking and cyber
attacks, but also the use of
social media, which Ukraine's
President Zelensky has excelled at
to project an aura of invincibility
and to cast the conflict in stark
terms of good versus evil.
This lesson shouldn't be new to
Americans, as our failures over
the past two decades in Afghanistan
and Iraq underscored the new reality
that old school invasion and
occupation is more expensive
and temporary than it is quick
and effective.
But Russia's incompetence drives
home in graphic detail to us,
and one hopes to the Chinese
officials supposedly eyeing an
invasion of Taiwan.
But even if Goliath does take
out David, the price is too
high and the victory too transition
to bother undertaking.
If the collapse of the Soviet Union,
that gargoyle incarnation
of belief in top down authority
power and decision making was the
beginning of the end of the 20th
century's romance with the nation
state than Russia's blundering in
Ukraine and the US's in Central
Asia and the Middle East may be its
epitaph.
The future belongs not to the
ignorant armies of the night who
seek to command and control,
but to those who embrace it and
power the decentralization of
weapons technology, information
currency and individual
ingenuity and courage.